listening to a film courage with
in cary war
there's a certain amount of a faith that
you have coming to Los Angeles you have
to have to like make that big of a move
and I think it was despite you know the
several difficulties we had you know
that I had it especially after
graduation trying to find work as a
screenwriter you know it was with the
residual faith you know I mean like you
still believe that something's gonna
happen so you stick with it you know and
there's something within every filmmaker
that does stick with it that you know
you have to protect and I think we
protected in the way that allowed us to
stay here instead of becoming so bitter
so angry you know you know i would
encourage everybody to look up the
filmmaker Zeke selker he's been doing
some regional screenings and actually
profiting off of them which goes against
the norm most people consider theatrical
a loss leader for their DVD or blu-ray
sales or you know any VOD deals that
they might have or there or you know any
other alternative methods of
distribution so um you know personally
we're looking forward to to
experimenting with a theatrical model
make it more event-based yeah absolutely
and and you know see if we can innovate
in any kind of way yeah I think there's
there's an ego that a lot of filmmakers
have in terms of their films have to be
in the theater for a full week you know
I mean like you need that full
theatrical run you know but that's not
really our space you know some of these
films are so small you know you don't
have the space that where people are
going to come out for a week straight